oh hi on this week's Game life we are
here at California extreme it is an
annual show where arcade and pinball
game collectors bring the gems of their
collection set them all up in one room
put them on free play and everybody gets
to go to town for a weekend now all the
games you remember for the heyday of our
caves and pinball are here but there's
also some crazy just one of a kind
things like marble man which is the
sequel to Marble Madness it was seen
every release there's only a couple of
them in the world and one of them is
here at California extreme so come along
with me let's take a look at some of the
crazy rare or just plain crazy games at
this year's show
so even if you know your pinball I
guarantee you've never seen these
machines behind me before and your life
these are not production pinball machine
these are machines made her tilt a 1979
movie starring a young Brooke Shields
fair one of a kind made only for the
movie and they're being shown here at
California extreme for the first time
since the 70s
now pinball is all well and good but
this is my jam as a kid growing up the
1990s you wanted your arcade to have a
time traveler machine you played a crazy
time traveling cowboy and you can travel
all the way back to 50,000 bc or forward
into the far-off future of 1998 the game
and let me tell you guys basically suck
it was pretty much dragon slayer but
worse but what made it cool was the fact
that it has this crazy hologram style
graphic it always drew a crowd and one
of the only places you can play time
traveller now is a portion at California
extreme
The Addams Family pinball machine is
considered one of the best pinball games
of all time but this version here is a
lot more difficult you have to actually
ride this bicycle the flipper controls
are on the handlebars and the flippers
don't work unless you're actively
pedaling the bike jinx who says gamers
don't get any exercise
well our day here at California extreme
is coming to an end we have played video
games and we have played pinball games
so what better to finish off on that a
combination video pinball game yes
that's right baby pac-man is an
exceedingly rare machine it combines a
game of pac-man with little half-size
game of pinball when pac-man goes out
the exits in the bottom the maze he pops
out in the pinball world it's a really
really crazy fun game it's so hard to
find one a working condition that's what
makes the California extreme show so
cool if you couldn't make it this year
it's held every year in july in Santa
Clara California it is like a dream for
people who fondly remember the 80s and
90s arcade scene we'll see you next week
I'm going to play me some baby back man
now